bonjour à tous bienvenue sur le site du
figaro ses points de vue c'est en direct
c'est en visio avec ce soir un nouveau
dans l'exercice bonsoir alexis poulain
bonsoir bio mais habitué du plateau le
mans mais pas encore habitués à la radio
même si on signale que vous avez un peu
essuyé les plâtres pendant là le
confinement puisque vous aviez été à des
premiers intervenants de la formule qui
a eu cours pendant le confinement qui
était à mon avis et vous répondiez à une
question
les français sont-ils indisciplinés et
je vous recommande bien de retrouver
c'est la réponse d'alexis parce qu'elle
était extrêmement clair elles étaient
tranchées et l été est payé et c'était
très intéressant jeu j'en profite pour
rappeler que vous êtes ancien
chroniqueur aux médias et fondateur du
site le monde moderne pour un média et
on recommande en particulier les
podcasts qui se trouve en plus des
informations et des analyses très
intéressante sur ce site
sophie de menthon est avec nos mouchoirs
sophie pour toi alors vous vous êtes
plus habitué à cet exercice vous vous y
êtes déjà à donner
on rappelle que vous êtes fondatrice du
mouvement pro entreprise éthique de la
fenêtre d'actrice
sa fondatrice ça a été fondée par papa
gâteux le père direct voire passe à gaza
par une longue attaque arrive ogata
donc vous avez été là reste vous a été
responsable de ce mouvement quand même
et on vous doit notamment la fête des
entreprises et le slogan j'aime ma boîte
et le livre très joli livre éternel
recommencement ce sont un recueil de
situation de citations choisies que vous
avez commenté
c'est aux éditions fortuna rachel by nas
est avec nous bonsoir rachel
vous êtes grand reporter vous collaborez
nombreux journaux notamment et
principalement à marianne et enfin
béatrice giblin bonsoir béatrice bon
sarrazin vous aussi vous êtes habitué de
l'exercice et on rappelle que vous êtes
disciples d'yves lacoste l'homme du
renouveau de la géopolitique en france
vous dirigez justement la revue la
passionnante revue hérodote dernière
livraison un numéro double donc la
géopolitique de la date à se faire et
rien que quand on regarde le titre est
bien on a envie de lire tout on est
intrigué et curieux de savoir ce qu'il
en sort est justement de la cartographie
parce que la date à se faire justement
c'est toujours quelque chose d'assez
d'assez confus à vous qui nous regardent
et à vous béatrice sophie alexis et
rachel je propose ce soir de revenir sur
deux thèmes
bien évidemment ces images qui font là
qui font la une et qui sidère l'opinion
publique qui sidère les réseaux sociaux
qui sidère la classe politique ces
violences à dijon
et aussi je vous propose de revenir sur
le démarrage des travaux de la
commission d'enquêté parlementaire sur
la gestion de la duc au vide de là que
vivent dix neuf si on suit les
recommandations de l'académie française
du coronavirus en tous les cas sur ces
sujets alexis sophie béatrice et rachel
et surtout vous qui nous regardent et
j'attends vos réactions j'attends vos
commentaires j'attends bien entendu vos
points de vue
[Musique]
alors après laurent us à la mi journée
c'est aujourd'hui en ce moment marine le
pen qui se trouve à dijon la président
du rassemblement national qui va faire
une conférence de presse que l'on pourra
entendre sur le site du figaro il n'en
reste pas moins que ce soit marine le
pen que ce soit les responsables
gouvernementaux que ce soit les autres
responsables politiques
il aura fallu attendre plusieurs jeux
plusieurs heures même plus de 24 heures
pour avoir cette réaction formelle de la
classe politique d'une mobilisation
qu'elle se rende sur place alors que
précisément ces images celle que vous
allez voir mais celle que vous avez déjà
vu tourner en boucle sur les réseaux
sociaux depuis plusieurs jours
maintenant
comme cette latence finalement quand on
regarde cette latence on se demande si
la classe politique n'est pas sidéré et
choqué interdite
un peu à l'image d'un homme pourtant
expérimenté en la matière le procureur
de la république de paris
françois molins j'avais vu des
affrontements entre communautés et des
problèmes communautaires dans certaines
villes je pense il ya très longtemps à
perpignan ou à nice même jeu bejo
j'avais jamais vu une telle intensité de
violence dans les affrontements entre
deux communautés de chaque chaîne et
maghrébine à dijon comme aujourd'hui et
plus globalement la délinquance explose
globalement je pense effectivement en 40
ans il ya certainement plus de violence
aujourd'hui qui en avait il ya quarante
ans ça c'est certain aussi à l'excès
poulain on vient d'entendre donc
françois molins de dire qu' il avait
n'avait jamais vu ça dans sa danse est
dans cette intensité mais qu'il avait
déjà vu des
qu'il avait déjà vu des conflits des
affrontements à nice et à perpignan que
la délinquance augmente
sachant également que la présence de
communautés d'origine étrangère avec est
également de plus en plus importante
j'ai envie de vous poser une question à
la verse de celles qu'on se pose depuis
24 heures mais est ce que ces
affrontements sont si étonnant du tout
ils jouent tous l'étonnement ils ont
poids des mots avec beaucoup de pudeur
le maire de dijon qui parle de petits
voyous qui demande aux jeunes de rester
chez eux
on a là affaire même plus à de la
délinquance c'est du crime organisé
c'est la pègre vous avez d'un côté la
mafia tchétchènes qui montre qu'elle
fait ce qu'elle veut en france qu'elle
défend son territoire qu'elle est au
dessus des lois françaises c'est
scandaleux
et puis vous avez de l'autre côté eh
bien les dealers qui tiennent les
quartiers qui créent des quartiers qu'on
appelle des zones de non droit où la
république n'existe pas ce sont des
forteresses du crime des forteresses du
trafic qui tiennent leur forteresse avec
cet armement qu'on a vu quand même un
arsenal d'artillerie lourde
vous avez de la kalachnikov du fusil
d'assaut des armes à ses récentes
d'ailleurs oui mais c'est important
parce qu'on soit derrière le politique
est en train de fait mise et il parle
d'affrontements communautaires il parle
de jeunes voyous il parle de deux choses
très légère alors qu'on a affaire en
fait à quelque chose qui verra ses
quartiers depuis des années qu'ils
volent nos paies de notre pays depuis
des années
si le crime organisé et c'est peut-être
la dernière chaîne de ce crime organisé
c'est à dire les petits dealers les gens
qui tiennent ces quartiers mais derrière
il ya beaucoup d'intérêts économiques il
ya des enjeux c'est kalachnikov
elles ne viennent pas de nulle part ça
s'achète sur des plaques tournantes
rappelé voulez quoi chine fournissait à
bruxelles par exemple quand la question
que ça pose en fait de voir ça
aujourd'hui c'est la question des moyens
du renseignement français parce qu'on
sait qu'il ya effectivement des arsenal
cachés dans les quartiers où ils le
trafic a lieu or on n'a jamais voulu
aller le chercher c'est dix moments
compliqués marseille on entend souvent
parler
là on parle de dijon c'est ça qui
surprend aussi c'est que c'est une ville
je la connais bien j'y suis né on
s'attend pas à ce genre de scène en fait
alors que marseille où on dit oui après
après tout eux c'est une plaque
tournante c'est comme ça on le sait la
french connection etc
non on voit l'ampleur du mal qui est
vraiment dans tous les quartiers de
toutes les villes de france et on n'a
pas voulu s'y attaquer tout simplement
parce que c'est compliqué parce qu'on en
a pas les moyens
la police demande des moyens le
renseignement demande des moyens
malheureusement le renseignement été
modifié quelques années on a fait
confiance au digital aux numériques
plutôt que au terrain et on en est là
comment 60 voitures de tchétchènes ont
pu traverser le pays pour se rendre à
dijon converger et faire ses scènes
d'émeutes au coeur de la ville place de
la république le samedi soir c'est
impressionnant n'aurait-on pas pu les
arrêter avant saisir ces armes
auparavant là vraiment on est sur un
problème beaucoup plus large que les
affrontements communautaires comme on
veut les appelait parfois mais celui du
crime organisé et des moyens que l'état
met face à ce crime pour que les
habitants de ces quartiers et une vie
normale et arrête de vivre dans la peur
on a bien compris je salue les
internautes qui se débattent déjà
intensément sur les forums du figaro
notamment christophe qui nous fait cette
observation qui étrenne je trouve très
intéressante
il a fallu trois jours et twitter pour
que les médias nationaux s'intéressent
enfin aux graves événements qui se
passent à dijon alors ce qui est vrai
christophe sait que c'est en voyant que
dijon était une tendance très forte sur
twitter qu'on a commencé à regarder mais
sa date d'un peu plus d'un peu plus tôt
que ce que vous dites mais c'est vrai
que c'est les les réseaux sociaux qui
ont été un peu un peu les lanceurs
d'alerté dans cette affaire et c'est là
où on a pu voir les images
rachel bina ce avant d'avoir votre
réaction
je voudrais qu'on écoute le secrétaire
d'état à l'intérieur puisque on en
parlait tout à l'heure le rendu n'est ce
donc qui était en milieu de journée sur
place
je veux passer un message très clair aux
voyous que nous avons vu exhibé des
armes aux individus qui sont venus comme
être ici des violences à dijon notre
réponse sera extrêmement fermé ce
dispositif sera maintenu
la réponse sera très ferme le dispositif
sera très maintenu sera maintenue c'est
ce que déclare laurent nièce hier à
audition publique quand on a interrogé
le secrétaire d'état gabriela talent
également disait que la réponse devait
être prêt fermé
mettez en avant tous les moyens de
police et de gendarmerie qui ont été
déployés est ce que ça vous rassure non
près sûr personne parce que parce qu en
fait personne n'y croit c'est si vous
voulez on a mis quand on a mis quand
même trois jours si je ne me trompe pas
trois jours avant d'interpeller quatre
individus la réponse très ferme
on l'a pas vu personne ne l'a vu cette
réponse extrêmement grasse tic
je pense qu'en réalité il ya il ya une
peur en fait en toile de fond on a cette
crainte d'un embrasement dans des zones
perdus de la république
on a le souvenir de 2005 qui encore
extrêmement prégnant et en réalité
derrière les mots il ya extrêmement peu
d'action on a vu ces scènes vous en avez
parlé des centaines de jeunes gens armés
qui devant les forces de l'ordre se
livrer à des règlements de comptes les
plus les plus violents qu'ils soient
donc dans quel pays similaires à la
france en termes de niveau de vie
on peut imaginer de telles scènes se
produire de guerre civile sans aucune
forme quasiment de répression parce que
quatre individus arrêtés serré c'est
rien du tout quand vous entendez le
préfet qui explique les forces de
l'ordre ont garanti le respect de la
paix publique et dans une situation
complexe en s'efforçant d'éviter tout
débordement
tout est dit tout est résumé dans sa
phrase c'est à dire que on baisse un
petit peu la tête
on espère que ça va se régler assez vite
que les tchétchènes rentreront chez eux
que les dealers reprendront le contrôle
du quartier et la vie continuera ainsi
sophie de menthon je voulais avoir votre
réaction votre avis c'était sur la
question d'ailleurs comme vous pose à
vous sur twitter trouvez vous que selon
vous le gouvernement est il dépassé par
les violences à dijon c'est un peu ce
que disait rachel à l'instant vous
n'êtes pas nombreux à avoir voté en
début d'émission là la question donc
vous est posée vous pouvez continuer à
voter pendant que on en discute on en
discute avec vous vous êtes très
nombreux à réagir vole pas eu nous nous
dit qu il ya eu des brigades qui ont été
installés en tout cas des forces de
l'ordre mais on a mais en plus on a fait
appel à des renforts donc la critique
est facile
est ce que vous partagez d'ailleurs cet
avis ou est ce que vous trouvez que la
réponse de l'état n'est pas à la hauteur
sophie là il évidemment la réponse n'est
pas à la hauteur le problème c'est que
voyez on attendait réaction
extraordinaire où se jettent sur ce que
va dire à un ministre ou un préfet ça
c'est plus du tout le sujet on doit
réagir apprendre parler je pense que là
il ya une espèce de pseudo guerre civile
on a d'ailleurs appelé l'armée je pense
qu'il faut mettre les moyens il faut
arrêter ça immédiatement mais je pense
que raquel avait tout à fait raison
on a peur on a peur j'appartiens moi
même je suis la réserve citoyenne de la
gendarmerie donc j'ai interrogé vu ce
qu'il en était et on m'a clairement dit
que quand on voulait nettoyer un
quartier parce qu'il ya un moment où
c'est ça on pouvait pas le faire parce
qu'avec ses réseaux en boucle sans arrêt
on a peur que tout s'embrase dans les
villes et nous n'avons pas les forces
suffisantes pour faire passer un
embrasement qui toucherait marseille
lyon paris gtrra est donc cette
mobilisation est grave
je pense qu'effectivement nos
renseignements généraux sont pas du tout
à la hauteur et qu'il faudrait commencer
pour voir un petit peu comment ça se
passe là ensuite de samoa pardonnez moi
alors je passe pour fâcher au ma foi on
envoie l'armée et on arrête ça c'est une
guerre alors on a peur aussi et c'est à
pau à je finis c'est un point très
important
on a tellement peur d'avoir un blessé ou
un mort et donc c'est ça le problème
et on voit aussi parce qu'on est en
pleine contradiction je veux dire aux
notes si on a des coups de pied on a
tiré si je puis dire verbalement en tout
cas sur les flics à n'en plus finir
ils sont soit disant violents des fachos
il ya des manifestations
on donne des coups de pieds dans leur
voiture comment voulez vous ça va les y
revenir mais pas gérer n'est pas tenue
et là je pense que les gens j'espère que
marine le pen doit pas tenir un discours
guerrier parce que elle va s'attirer à
nombre de voix incroyable on va on va on
va y revenir justement sur la sphère des
armes mais apparemment je voulais
béatrice votre réaction
d'abord sur ce que vient de dire sophie
parce que c'est également ce que dit un
certain nombre d'internautes
laurence qui nous dit fait intervenir
l'armée pour que tout ça s'arrête on est
dans une situation où le gouvernement
doit prendre une décision ferme jean
paul nous dit c'est un miracle qu'il n'y
ait pas eu de victime
en revanche l'omar nous dit le
gouvernement n'est pas dépassé par la
situation à dijon le ggn y était cette
nuit la nuit a été calme
le raid a été déployé également
aujourd'hui quel est votre point de vue
est peut-être une question subsidiaire
on parle de conflits importés mais en
réalité ce sont de nouveaux conflits se
sont pas de les sociétés des tchétchènes
et les maghrébins sont pas des gens qui
se qui se confrontent
habituellement il ya pas de guerre
ailleurs c'est la ccc c'est une nouvelle
confrontation qu'on a sur notre
territoire alors
triste montant
je suis pas sûre que
tris m'entendent en tout cas moi je
l'entends pas alors je l'entends pas
donc on va relancer pour que le a à leur
tour voilà le retour bien triste oui
alors vous me demander ma réaction
écoutez moi je me retiendrais parler de
guerre civile la guerre civile c'est une
chose beaucoup trop grave qui marquent
quand même des esprits pour très très
longtemps pensé à l'espagne
voilà dont on n'est même pas totalement
encore dans l'histoire tout à fait sorti
donc il faut mesurer nos propos et je ne
parlerai même pas de guerre que je
cherche
on n'a pas eu de mort on a quatre
blessés aussi blessé peut-être on a eu
des voitures qui ont brûlé
oui il en brûle à strasbourg tous les 31
décembre on a vu des poubelles ont brûlé
alors je ferai attention vocabulaire que
j'utilise donc je ne parlerai pas de
guerre civile
je ne parlerai pas de galère mais la
situation est tout à fait important
je ne dirais pas que toutes les
agglomérations françaises sont dans la
même situation je ne dirais pas que tous
les quartiers sont dans la même
situation pour avoir dirigé une thèse
sur le trafic des petites armes et des
armes de poing
je sais très bien l'importance de la
circulation des armes en france elle
n'est pas qu'à marseille elle est
d'ailleurs la plus nombreuse et ça va
vous surprendre en milieu rural plus
qu'en milieu urbain
parce que tant qu'à faire quand on veut
faire du trafic d'armes on le fait dans
des endroits où on est un peu masqué où
on vient pas trop vous garder et on se
met pas à faire des gros c'est des
réserves d'armes dans le quartier nord
de marseille passant parce que là on est
sûr qu'on va venir nous chercher
donc il ya des certain nombre de
représentations sur lequel il faudrait
revenir
ceci étant ce qui s'est passé est une
affaire tout à fait sérieuse si on n'a
pas réagi tout de suite c'est ce qu'a
expliqué je pense raquel binard mais
c'est aussi ce qu'a expliqué je croise
ofid mentaux c'est à dire la crainte de
l'embrasement
en 2005 on avait un ministre de
l'intérieur qui s'appelait nicolas
sarkozy qui a avoué le contact
et c'est dans toutes les analyses qui
ont été faites très sérieuse prouve
qu'être aller au contact a été une des
causes de cet embrasement
alors faut-il en contact et jouer les
boisements pour jouer du rapport de
force
ou faut-il comme l'a dit je crois que ce
serait nous presser en cercle et
encadrée et éviter que ça se propage
très rapidement
béatrice béatrice béatrice rapidement je
voulais qu à avoir votre votre point de
vue justement de spécialistes de
géopolitique alors sur les armes
on recommandera les travaux de quelqu'un
qui a suivi l'institut de géopolitique
c'est jean charles antoine qui était un
spécialiste dans la gendarmerie et une
autre question que je voulais vous poser
si vous m'entendez
oui très bien c'est on parle de quoi
alors moi je ne parle pas de guerre je
parle de médias d'une confrontation même
un conflit en parle de conflits importés
mais en réalité ce n'est pas un conflit
importé entre d'un côté des
ressortissants maghrébins et des
ressortissants tchétchènes ou d'origine
maghrébine et les ressortissants
tchétchènes n'y a pas de guerre entre
deux chaises tchétchénie et pays du
monde maghrébin
par contre ce sont des nouveaux conflits
qui gâte sur notre territoire
bien sûr que c'est des conflits qui
existent sur le territoire elle qui
existe déjà depuis longtemps pour avoir
travaillé 30 ans seine-saint-denis faut
vous dire que ce genre de conflit ça
existe en tanzanie et les pieds de
chaîne c'est pas des enfants de choeur
un défier le jeu mafia tchétchène
puisque c'est toujours pas sorti de mon
temps qu'il a cité la mafia tchétchène
s'est effectivement des gens armés
extrêmement dangereux alors on va y
revenir à grévin ont le contrôle de la
drogue c'est c'est pas du tout les gens
gentils sabbatique et aux trains ils
sont dangereux jeu à prendre
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait on peut pas
les coacher les choses comme ça mais je
pense qu'on lutte contre la mouche dans
ce pays et je ne pense qu'on lutte
contre on a vraiment écouté on ne sait
pas où on va pas le nous régler comme ça
non mais quand même qui est sûr c'est
que il ya des choses qui sont pas à un
niveau très local de dealers important
mais ce qui est très bon on sait d
essayer
coffret beaucoup plus haut c'est ce que
la police essaye de faire moi je fais
pas un discours anti poli je pense
qu'ils font leur travail du mieux
possible mais que c'est extrêmement
difficile
alors justement alors justement
justement sur ça puisque la police a été
mise en cause
je voudrais quand même qu'on regarde de
nouveau des images vous y avez fait
largement allusion depuis le début de ce
débat malgré des problèmes techniques
on a vu des images dont ces images où ce
sont des armes qui ont été brandis les
images tournent en boucle et la question
et ça je la poserai tout à l'heure à
alexis poulain est ce que ça remet pas
en cause cette déclaration de jean luc
mélenchon il y a quelques jours il doit
y avoir une police à peu près partout
mais ça doit être une police pensée
organisée disciplinée obéissante à
l'état républicain et ne se constituant
pas comme une sorte de forteresse a pas
une police aussi désarmé que possible
pour qu'elle inspire le respect des
citoyens ça doit être ça leur objectif
leur objectif ça doit pas être de faire
peur mais d'être respecté l'objectif
c'était pas de faire peur mais d'être
respectés et une police aussi des armes
est possible est ce que regarde ce qu'on
vient de voir alexis ses déclarations de
jean luc mélenchon reste pertinente
alors il parlait pas de ça c'était avant
les émeutes
il parlait de débat qui a eu sur le
violence les cas de violence dans
l'exercice du métier de policier
ce qu'il dit c'est simple c'est éviter
l' escalade lui on arme d'un côté plus
en armes de l'autre donc dans une vision
lui joue son rôle de pacifistes
évidemment lui ont des armes lourdes et
armes et il faut que ça des armes dans
les deux côtés et quand on voit ce qui
se passe à dijon évidemment se rend
compte que on ne peut pas envoyer une
police désarmés face à des bandes
lourdement armés à des gangs mafieux
lourdement armés donc il ya un problème
mais il parlait pas de cette police l'a
d'ailleurs il a hilare le fait un tweet
ou l'art parlé en disant il va falloir
désarmer les gangs et donc il
faut désarmer tout le monde c'est aussi
simple que ça parce qu'effectivement
quand on regarde la façon dont les crs
sont habillés au delà de ça mais en
manifestation l'évolution de la bi de
celui qui incarne la force publique qui
est pensé maintenant pour faire peur en
temps ne reconnaît plus l'homme derrière
la machine on voit vraiment une machine
de guerre qui avance devant les
manifestants ce n'était pas le cas il ya
quelques années on voyait encore l'homme
sous un blouson derrière un bouclier
transparents là on a affaire à une
cuirasse et c'est vrai que ça peut faire
peur et on peut se donner aux placements
non non c'est pas le rôle de la non
attendez l'équipe il avec un petit bâton
blanc leur niveau mais vous savez c'est
ce qui se passe c'est ce qui se passe en
allemagne c'est ce qui se passe au pays
bas il ya des il ya des doctrines du
maintien de l'ordre qui sont très
différentes en france on a choisi la
violence
c'est regrettable et je pense que c'est
ça une désescalade
et après évidemment que on en voit dans
les quartiers on en voit leur raid on
envoie là-bas qu on envoie des gens qui
sont armés et formés à des malfaiteurs
la mélenchon par led et des gens qui est
nommé l'accord de faire un championnat
si on gagne pas mélanger les choses
et moi je sais pas plus regardons donc
aller après la réponse de sophie voilà
donc il faut pas mélanger les choses
il yad'un côté effectivement cette
police armée qui est d'ailleurs la
gendarmerie qui l a formés pour
intervenir dans des situations de crise
extrême qui est armé formé à
l'utilisation des armes et de l'autre
côté il faudrait pas rentrer dans
justement une course à l'armement tu
sois la police municipale ou d'autres
parce que justement le monde de plus en
plus violents alors oui on est loin
oui on en est loin mais il ya quelque
chose qui va vers ça et malheureusement
le monde est de plus en plus violent
mais est-ce que l' escalade de la
violence peut s'arrêter un moment et est
ce que c'est les armes qui font la
désescalade
non les armes ne font qu'ajouter à la
viola l'orage la hure on parle et
d'armures et l'hypothèque et les
policiers se protège et je pense que
c'est important je pense que le respect
de ces malfrats
c'est aussi d'avoir des types équipés en
face d'eux on sait très bien que la
police manque d'équipements qu'ils ont
des voitures qui sont incapables de
poursuivre le moindre des lacs en moi je
pense que là
on peut pas dire ah oui on a perdu ce
cadre vous avez raison ils ont vraiment
peur des escalades
mais il ya un moment où il faut réagir
avec violence on ne peut pas opposer ils
ont posé leurs menottes pendant ce temps
là j'y reviens pas avec violence oui
d'accord alors explique moi la
différence entre la violence elle est
aveugle c'est à dire que vous avez après
les vifs il est évidemment d un problème
de maths alors vous avez une doctrine
vous avez une déontologie vous ne pouvez
pas utiliser la violence va dire
totalement une boule et appeler ça de la
forte demande pas mieux si la force et
efficace j'en suis enchantée mais mais
quand vous appelez des gens qui ont qui
sont armés face à d'autres gens qui sont
armés
il ya une forme de violence quand même
donc je pense que voir ça oui georges e
on a bien compris le point de vue des
ternes le débat votre point de vue
rachel je vous vois en train de vous
franchement oui c'est en fait cif j'ai à
la fois une forme d'admiration et
d'exaspération par rapport à ce que
j'entends c'est le jeu il faut vraiment
appartenir à une certaine bourgeoisie
pour considérer aujourd'hui que le
problème ce sont les policiers trop
armée et que l'objectif principal de
notre société doit être le fait de les
désarmer et que parce qu'on a les
désarmer de l'autre côté
grâce à un récit remicade incroyable de
l'autre côté ils vont répondre par la
même chose ce que ce qu'il faudrait par
contre soul mais ce qui est important
c'est qu'en effet en manifestant lors
des manifestations les policiers les
gendarmes portent réellement leur badge
d'identification ce qui n'est pas
toujours le cas ça en effet c'est un
sujet mais celui d'un problème d'armes
qui appellerait en retour une autre
violence
enfin c'est vraiment ne pas connaître du
tout ces milieux là je veux dire c c c c
est à quel point cette situation enfin
un moment vous vous heurtez aux réelles
quand même pas vous rendez compte avec
ces événements que le problème c'est pas
que l'urgence de notre pays c'est pas
désarmer les policiers ou répondre au
racisme systémique comme a pu le faire
mélenchon à certains égards en
participant à certaines manifestations
le problème aujourd'hui c'est ya un
certain nombre de territoires
sont devenus quasiment plus fort que les
forces de l'ordre elles mêmes la
violence n'est pas un gros mot
la violence elle peut être aussi
légitime elle peut être encadré c'est ce
qu'il faut aussi qu'on vit dans voilà
dans une civilisation dans une société
encadré avec un respect c'est pas la loi
des plus forts normalement c'est ce vers
quoi on tend donc ça doit pas être un
gros mot que de dire qu'il ya une
violence les désarmer il faut voir un
parcours en place
c'est à dire que enlever la clé
d'étranglement si c'est pour le
remplacer par le teaser
personnellement ça m'intéresse peu donc
il faut voir aussi dans les pays qui ont
décidé de supprimer un certain nombre de
techniques par quoi ils les ont
remplacés c'est pas forcément plus doux
loin de là et puis il ya un autre sujet
qu'on n'a pas abordé mais qui en fait
parfaitement écho c'est le clientélisme
aujourd'hui parce que si ces territoires
soient aussi très forte c'est parce qu
un clientélisme de la part d'élus locaux
qui également aussi très puissant
j'entends demain je lisais en france
bleu l'adjoint au maire déléguée au
quartier des grésillés le quartier qui
nous occupe actuellement
hamid al sonni dire commenter les
événements en expliquant que les
habitants du quartier avaient tout
simplement garantie eux mêmes leur
sécurité nous expliquer qu'il n'était
pas une question de trafic de drogue ou
de guerre deux communautés
c'est quand même un petit peu léger d'en
arriver là bien après ce jumelage je
partagerai le point de vue elle et je
pense que il y à des techniques de
maintien de l'ordre du contrôle de
situation que c'est pas celle ci que de
là où nous sommes on peut toujours dire
eh ben on n'a qu'à y aller on envoie
l'armée on va régler ça d'un coup de
cuillère à pot elie comprendront où est
la loi où est le plus fort je pense qu
on a une police et les responsables de
la police qui sont très conscients des
difficultés des dangers et que moi
j'aurais eu une attitude qui serait sera
beaucoup plus j'allais dire un mot et
respectueuse du travail qu'ils font
voilà moi je la respecte a travaillé
pour téléphoner
je maintiens qu'il ne sait on a eu
peut-être six blessés on n'a pas eu de
mort
on a exhibé effectivement des armes il
ya eu aucune force de l'ordre qui a été
touché on a brûlé des voitures et des
poubelles je le redis elle peut être que
seriez à quoi elles vont se reproduire
cette situation vont se reproduire et je
me refuse à parler de guerre civile
enfin je compense les thèmes que vous
avez utilisés sont d'accord avec vous et
je partagerai beaucoup plus le point de
vue d'alexis roussat sur la mesure où on
aura vous avez peut-être pas entendu
mais justement sophie a dit allez
peut-être été un peu loin dans les mots
mais en tous les cas les actes de guerre
mais ce sont des actes de guerre on a
bien compris ce que vous avez dit nicole
nous dit si on parlait aussi de la
justice surtout les japs terre des juges
d'application des peines qui leur
mettent dehors sitôt arrêté et on a
également donc nicole qui s'indignent
sous prétexte de paix sociale on a
laissé faire la racaille partout
maintenant on le paye jean baptiste lui
s'indigne on envoie la police lorsque
les gilet jaune manifeste et dans le cas
de dijon où est la police alors je pense
jean baptiste que on a vu depuis quand
même quelques heures la police déployé
deux corps d'élite notamment le gign et
le raid
evelyne nous dit ce qui fait peur c'est
que nous n'avons pas de gouvernement
capable d'éradiquer ce à la faiblesse
des réponses laissent libre cours à tous
les débordements c'est la question qu'on
vous pose est d'ailleurs sur twitter
est-ce que vous pensez que le
gouvernement est à la hauteur dans la
gestion de ce qui se passe à dijon est
pour l'instant vous êtes une large
majorité à avoir répondu non vous êtes
nombreux à le vote continue c'est en
direct de plus de 200 votes alors que on
va commencer l'émission on vous étiez
moins 200 à avoir voté merci d'avoir
participé donc à cette question